[inaudible]
the alliance between the United States
and the European countries is not
exactly having its best moments right
now.
Donald Trump has made quite an inference
and as jeopardize the relationship of
these nations who an extent that they
could even possibly break up.
We have seen that with the Paris
agreement,
make our planet great the game and also
with Donald Trump's position towards
NATO,
the most powerful military organization
in history and I never asked watch what
the new NATO headquarters cost.
I refuse to do that.
In this video we're going to focus on
this organization.
We're going to look at what's happening
with Neato,
why Donald Trump is criticizing.
It's so much and what the future is for
this organization,
but before we get into any of that,
let's get some perspective.
NATO,
I'll look back
shortly after the ends of World War Two,
the North Atlantic Treaty Organization,
it took its first steps.
It was born in 1949 with a very clear
mission,
restrain,
stop,
and if needed,
defeat the Soviet Union.
The Cold War had just started and there
was an atmosphere of tension.
The Berlin blockade is already taking
place in the Czech Communist Party,
had completely taking control with acute
attack.
At that time,
nobody knew what was going to happen.
The Ans,
the possibility of war was very,
very real.
So let's take a look at the historical
context.
The world had just gone through World
War Two.
Europe was destroyed and there was an
absolute distrust on both sides.
The truth is the door wouldn't have been
a surprise and that was the situation
which existed when NATO was born.
At the beginning,
NATO was formed by the United States,
Canada,
and 10 European countries,
France,
Italy,
the United Kingdom,
Belgium,
the Netherlands,
Luxembourg,
Denmark,
Norway,
Iceland,
and portrait.
A few years later,
the federal public of Germany or western
Germany was added to that.
The general purpose of the idea,
a bit spirits,
so to speak,
was to bring it forces together.
If a man become,
she was attacked.
It was seen as if all the members had
been attacked as well.
Over 101 for all,
right?
Well,
yes,
but also not quite because there was
quite and lots of small prints.
NATO after the colon.
However,
that all changed in 1991 the fall of the
Soviet Union left Neato with no clear
Parvis without an enemy.
What is the point of the alliance?
That is a question many people asked and
many still do today,
but wait one second because against all
odds,
it was actually after the fall of the
Soviet Union that the organization
started to play a more active role.
It is
take an action quite frequently since
then.
It's includes Serbia,
Kosovo,
Afghanistan,
Libya,
control over the Baltic Sea.
It gets piracy and the Indian Ocean and
recently support for the fight against
Isis
was also during this time when more new
countries that signed up since it
started in corporations have been
regular,
but since 1991 in corporations have
really sped up.
there were 12 countries in NATO.
Today there are 28 many of these
countries are from the old Warsaw Pact,
a similar thing to NATO,
but led by the Soviets
hands.
Putin's Russia has never liked that.
In fact of the award of 2008 between
Russia and Georgia took place,
partly because Georgia wanted to become
a member of NATO and something similar
has happened in the Ukraine,
ends after the recent crisis in Ukraine
and the clash between them and Russia,
NATO seems to have sped up again.
[inaudible]
also in 2016 and immediate action force
was set up.
This is made of 5,000 soldiers capable
of deploying very quickly and in almost
any place.
The socal audit spearhead force has
5,000 soldiers that are part of a larger
rapid action force of 40,000 soldiers.
In order to coordinate it's deployments
via alliance has created since
September,
2014 eight support headquarters in all
the countries that used to be under
Soviet influence.
And then 2017 the United States made the
largest troop deployments in Europe
since the Cold War following a NATO
mission.
Thousands of US troops arrive in Europe
in one of the largest deployments since
the cold
or we all talking about more than 4,000
soldiers and hundreds of tanks and
armored vehicles already being deployed
in eastern Europe on a mission that
reminds us of the initial mission of
NATO to discourage Russia from any
expansionist temptations.
However,
despite all of this activity,
the role of NATO is still uncertain and
the United States is still unhappy with
the commitments from the organizations.
European partners.
Yes.
The anger of the United States.
I was saying,
oh,
the Rom the mutual defense guarantee you
if a member of NATO is a tax is not as
clear as it seems.
Take a look at article five the one that
regulates this situation.
Parties
agree that an armed attack against one
or more of them shall be considered it
an attack against them all.
And consequently they agree that if such
an attack occurs,
each of them will assist the party or
parties.
So attacked by taking forth with such
actions as it deems necessary,
including the use of armed force article
five of the North Atlantic Treaty,
including the use of armed forces.
This means the Tipi country were to
suffer an attack.
It doesn't mean the rest have to give
immediate military support and that is
why all of the presidents of the United
States,
since Harry Truman have taken advantage
of the first NATO meeting they attended
to in article five as a commitment of
military force.
Yeah.
How are the Donald Trump hasn't,
he was expected to do so during the
inauguration of a monument for victims
of nine 11 in Brussels where he attended
his first meeting meeting.
Indeed,
he was asked to do so by the European
countries.
The White House have said that they
would,
but a final commitment was not
forthcoming.
There are analysts that think this is a
major issue and they refer to this as
one of the biggest diplomatic mistakes
of all time.
Other analysts don't think this is so
important,
but what is undeniable is that this has
not been well received in Europe,
especially for these reasons.
Yeah,
okay.
Till now,
the only country which is invoked
article five was the United States.
They did it after nine 11 and they
received immediate support from all
members of NATO.
Okay.
Well thing is that trump didn't want to
offer support and actually he took
advantage of his speech.
Do you recrimination the alleged lack of
commitments by his European allies?
He
Europeans what?
Dedicating a monument to remember the
888 European,
158 Canadian and 2,396 American troops
who died in Afghanistan took some doing
Thomas,
right?
Let's,
trump is not the only one angry about
it.
Bama.
He had the same opinion.
And the question is now,
why is the United States so angry at
NATO?
Well basically because they claim that
the European members of NATO on not
committed enough or don't spend enough
money
rule.
All NATO members are committed to
spending at least 2% of their GDP on
defense.
However,
only a few countries and meeting this
commitment,
these include the United Kingdom,
Poland,
Sonia Greece,
and of course the united,
the rest welfare,
quite some way from spending that
amounts.
Just taking a look at what trump's
secretary of defense,
James Mattis has to say about the
European countries.
Americans cannot care more for your
children's future security than you do.
Now wait a second,
because it does this mean that the
European countries don't spend money on
defense?
Well,
that's certainly not the case.
In fact,
if we add up all of the budgets of all
European countries that are members of
NATO,
these countries spend $250 billion every
year.
So you're with these countries were one,
it would be the country with the second
highest military spending after only the
United States.
So if it's money we're talking about,
it's not that spending has been reduced
or at least not relative to the threats
of the world is currently facing times.
They're pretty different sands.
We don't live with a Soviet Union
anymore,
and obsession of the United States,
let us say it loud and clear.
The world has changed and we are facing
different difficulties than we were ever
in the 1960s the risk today is not just
the possibility of a great war.
This risk has been reduced by
globalization,
trade and mutually assured destruction.
The threats we face today can be found
in terrorism,
piracy,
cyber warfare,
am's,
the risk of the proliferation of weapons
of mass destruction.
So must we fight these risks?
Well,
certainly this is something that we
won't accomplish with more tanks.
We also need to consider that we are
dealing with a very different kind of
water date,
something known as hybrid warfare where
combat isn't like what it was in older
movies.
Most of the wars are more and more often
about gorillas and as groups aimed at
destabilizing nations.
Other that is political pressure,
economic penalties,
cyber warfare,
interference.
In the election processes,
intelligence,
operations,
et Cetera,
that make wall much more company.
Okay.
To the mistakes of Europe,
one thing is clear,
they see numbers on not doing everything
right.
On the one hand is the organization has
established a more sensible conditions.
20% of the budget should be spent on
equipment here.
Even European countries,
which spends more on soldiers than they
need still arms meeting this
requirements on the other hands.
European countries,
I'll still quite disorganized and use
very different systems,
which makes production maintenance and
deployments more ends more expensive.
Just have a look at what happens with
tech.
The United States primarily uses one
kind of tank,
the Abrams tank,
while the Europeans use it to 19
different models.
Imagine the chaos when he joined
deployments.
It has to be organized.
They can't even share the same
replacement equipments and as well the
same is true for much more than just
tanks.
And so the final question is,
can it may say play a significant role
in the future?
In our opinion here,
a visual politic,
yes,
they absolutely can,
but only after a bit of a perspective
shift.
We feel that countries can spend money
better and actually share resources
rather than just spending more,
even though that might upset some
military contractors.
Well now we'd like to know your opinion.
Now,
what should the future of NATO beat?
Do you think that the European countries
that should meet to the U S is demands?
Or do you think a NATO,
you should focus less on conventional
warfare?
Or maybe you think,
Nita,
you should just dissolve.
Let us know what you think in the
comments below.
So well,
I really hope you enjoyed that video and
please do hit that like button if you
did.
And don't forget to subscribe if you
haven't already for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday and don't
forget to check.
And our friends at be reconsidered media
podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode
but aren't mine.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next video.